30 mais d'abord la synthèse des annonces
d'olivier ferrand et les premières
réactions au sénat avec cesser la
section pas de confinement de couvre-feu
de fermeture des commerces ou de
limitation des déplacements pour faire
face à la cinquième vague le
gouvernement n'a pas fait le choix de
mesures strictes depuis deux ans la
donne a changé et nous avons les moyens
de nous prémunir individuellement et
collectivement des conséquences
dramatiques
des premières vagues grâce à l'une des
couvertures vaccinales les plus fortes
au monde grâce aux gestes barrières
grâce au pass sanitaires olivier ferrand
a donc annoncé un renforcement de la
vaccination et notamment l'ouverture de
la troisième dose à partir d'aujourd'hui
pour tous les plus de 18 ans et des cinq
mois après leur dernière injection un
rappel qui sera désormais obligatoire
pour l'obtention du pass sanitaire sept
mois au plus tard après la deuxième
injection autre annonce les tests pcr
seront valables 24 heures au lieu de 72
jusqu'à présent très concrètement si
vous n'êtes pas encore vaccinés et si
vous souhaitez bénéficier du pass
sanitaires vous devrez donc vous faire
tester tous les jours à vos frais sauf
si vous êtes symptomatique avec une
ordonnance de votre médecin sauf si vous
êtes reconnu qu'à contacter par l'
agence régionale de santé oms par
l'assurance maladie une manière de
mettre la pression sur les non vaccinés
pour le sénateur et l'air rené paul
savary mais ces contraintes qui font que
les gens se disent je peux pas rester en
dehors du circuit par ma foi si ça peut
aider en convaincre certains de pas tous
les joueurs allaient avoir des tests qui
sont quand même pas très agréable les
contraindre à se vacciner bas ma foi
pourquoi pas quoi enfin le gouvernement
propose de ne plus systématiquement
fermer les classes en primaire quand un
élève et testés positifs mais de
dépister tous les élèves et seuls ceux
qui ont commis des restaurants à la
maison pour le sénateur bernard jomier
le gouvernement fait fausse route cette
mesure ne permettra pas de faire baisser
la circulation du virus on ne fait pas
de dépistage
répéter on fera des dépistages en cas de
symptômes et ça c'est une erreur parce
que ça maintient au niveau de
circulation du virus parmi les enfants
le gouvernement a également annoncé la
veille six nations pour les 5-11 ans à
partir du début de l'année 2022 sous
réserve d'un avis favorable de l'agencé
du médicament
on analyse ces mesures annoncées par
olivier verront leur acceptation aussi
par la population avec mes invités je
vous présente christine rouzioux en soir
bienvenue bonsoir est professeur émérite
de virologie à la faculté de médecine de
necker membres de la cellule covit de
l'académie de médecine fanny paris ce
soir anthropologue chercheur associé à
l'université de lausanne spécialiste des
modes de vie emmanuel rivière bonsoir
politologue directeur international pour
les études politiques de kantar public
et lætitia truffaz éditorialistes
bonsoir
laetitia christine rouzioux vous porter
le masque c'est un message que vous
faites pas c'est évidemment c'est humain
je crois que là il va falloir vraiment
s'y remettre et et on sait que ça
protège on sait que même vacciner on
peut attraper le virus donc voilà pour
limiter la circulation du virus c'est
indispensable
et je pense que pas mal de réunions
maintenant ou voilà il va falloir s'y
mettre voir si quiconque est abandonné
et je pense que là c'est
le relâchement est terminée oui
évidemment nous on a on calcule les
distances sur le plateau de public sénat
mais c'est de cet intéressant à ce que
ce que vous dites parce que
l'acceptation du mas finalement on avait
c'est symbolique on a vu un peu le
sentiment de s'en être débarrassé sans
doute à tort mais là il va falloir
effectivement là nos bureaux cet après
midi on l'avait tous remis enfin voila
c'est cette acceptation à sais pas si
simple dans une autre mine au public
l'acceptation du masque est pas si
simple mais c'était un des objets
symboliques et un totem du début de
cette crise est un symbole le
détachement par rapport aux masses
c'était aussi un symbole de reprise de
nos libertés une impression que le virus
circule et moins que la pandémie était à
distance et que d'un côté on arrivait à
maîtriser en quelque sorte le risque à
l'échelle de sa vie quotidienne leurs
maîtres c'est une manière aussi de
signifier que la pandémie est le risque
est toujours présent et que le
relâchement
par rapport aux gestes barrière doit
être stoppée alors on va parler
évidemment de ceux de ce pass sanitaire
nouvelle formule et on écoute tout de
suite olivier ferrand se passe bientôt
désactivé pour ceux qui n'auront pas
leur rappelle le ministre compter du 15
décembre le pas salutaire pour les plus
de 65 ans ne sera plus actif si le
rappelle n'a pas été fait dans un délai
de sept mois après l'infection ou après
la dernière injection
et à compter du 15 janvier se passe
sanitaires de tous les autres publics
c'est à dire les français âgés de 18 à
64 ans ne sera plus actif si le rappelle
n'a pas été fait dans ce délai qui reste
inchangé de sept mois après la dernière
injection
rivière s il faudrait pas commencer à
parler d'impasse vaccinale ce serait pas
complètement inappropriée mais c'est
aussi dans la suite ce qui a été
appliqué et finalement tout le monde on
s'en souvient ne pas aller vers la
vaccination dans le pays avec
enthousiasme mais ce qui n'était pas
très allants pour le faire n'était pas
forcément farouchement hostile pour la
grande majorité d'entre eux les gens
étaient un peu hésitant il avait besoin
d'en savoir plus ils avaient besoin
d'être rassurés et finalement dans
l'hésitation le fait d'ajouter un
système de contraintes a fait
qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas loin de 90 %
la population adulte qui vacciner pas
tous avec enthousiasme mais tous parce
que ben ils ont fait un peu leur marché
entre ce que ça représentait comme
danger ce que voulait dire ne pas avoir
le pass le souvenir qu'ils avaient des
lourdes contraintes que l'on n'avait que
l'on avait vécu et ses règles il faut
vraiment avoir en tête que l'opinion
publique bouge énormément sur ce sujet
il ya un an quand un public mesurait que
il y avait à peine un tiers des français
35% qui considérait que la vaccination
qui est annoncé par pfizer comme
possible devait être obligatoire
aujourd'hui on est à 68 % qui considère
que ça pourrait être obligatoire les
gens ont bougé parce que entre temps on
a fait aussi l'expérience d'une
vaccination qui n'a pas eu
effets secondaires aussi grain que dans
certains noeuds dans certains moments
d'ailleurs cette hypothèse enfin la
troisième dose de vaccin testé par oddo
xai black bones consulting pour le
figaro publié hier les français
favorables à à 78% c'est assez
intéressant laetitia cette séquence la
con et qu'on est en train de vivre
comment vous l'analysez ça commence avec
les sondages pour essayer de ça
s'appelle aussi des ballons d'essai pour
voir un peu comment réagit l'opinion
publique avant cette nouvelle séquence
de conférence de presse dont on avait
l'habitude c'était à 19 heures avant et
puis ça a glissé à 12h30 avec les mêmes
olive et veyran avec le directeur
général de la santé qui nous annonce des
mesures que finalement nous connaissons
déjà si on est un peu attentif aux
médias c'est à dire que de façon assez
institutionnalisée aujourd'hui les
mesures principales fuite avant dans la
presse deux à deux jours à 24 heures
avant et ensuite on a l'habitude de les
réécouter alors on peut se dire ah c'est
à cause de ces parlementaires qui ont
rendez vous avec le premier ministre
c'est un peu ce qui se dit côté
politique ce sont les parlementaires qui
finalement arrose la presse de sms pour
dire avant l'heure quelles vont être les
mesures or il me semble quand même que
ça arrange le gouvernement pourquoi
parce que répétait un message c'est en
communication le meilleur moyen de faire
adopter ce message donc à la limite que
ça sorte deux jours avant que ce soit
redit et puis qu'on puisse diffuser au
plus grand nombre je pense que c'est
dans l'intérêt du gouvernement oui vous
avez été surprise par la présence du
directeur général de la santé jérôme
salomon oui j'avais des conférences de
presse pourquoi j'avais déjà été
surprise en septembre quand villa il
avait repris la parole parce que une
dépêche afp l'avait annoncé partant le
14 juillet c'est à dire que c'était une
nouvelle qui avait été reprise par tous
les médias ça m'était donnée par paris
match et ensuite reprise puisque validé
par la lfp et une porte parole du
ministère de la santé avait confirmé le
départ de jérôme salle aux mots sans
préciser la date puisque on attendait de
savoir qui allait le remplacer pour
ensuite vraiment communiquer sur son
départ or il ya eu l'été entre cette
annonce et en tout cas la réapparition
de jérôme salomon qui n'a pas quitté son
poste visiblement de directeur général
de la santé et en conscience est
problématique c'est problématique parce
qu'une commission du sénat il y avait
imputé la responsabilité
du stock de masques qui n'était pas
suffisant c'était une commission qui
dataient de fin de l'année de décembre
2020 et donc lui avait répondu
évidemment à 7 cette commission à ces
enquêtes olives et les rangs avait
balayé d'un revers de main ces
accusations mais il me semble que quand
on porte une communication aussi crucial
que celle sur coville quand l'émetteur
est abîmée et visiblement jérôme salomon
à sa crédibilité
abîmée ça commence à être problématique
dans encore une fois un processus de
communication est d'ailleurs bon il
c'est pas lui qui est en première ligne
dans cette communication mais
effectivement c'est intéressant
christine où je voudrais revenir sur ce
timing des annonces est sûre finalement
cette course contre la montre parce que
c'est un peu ça avec le virus et
l'épidémie est ce que cette décision
aurait pu être prise plus tôt il ya une
semaine ya quinze jours peut-être dans
l'est clairement les choses étaient
différentes ya quinze jours clairement
les choses s'emballent et là le virus
x 2 chaque jour ça devient une
un développement exponentiel qui fait
que clairement la situation est quand
même nettement nettement plus mauvaises
qui a quinze jours la semaine dernière
moi je commençais vraiment à m'énerver à
me dire c'est maintenant pas il faut il
faut y aller maintenant parce que le
timing est restreint il nous reste juste
quelques semaines avant noël il faut
qu'on arrive à vacciner un maximum de
gens en quête semaine donc je trouve que
les enjeux ont été à peu près compris
dans la mesure où
les dates
apposez vont vont vraiment faire que les
gens vont y aller et en plus je pense
que il ya beaucoup plus de gens qui
acceptent et qu'ils ont compris
l'intérêt les résultats sont vraiment
très bons pour cette troisième dose puis
tout le monde a envie de passer des
vacances à peu près normale donc on a
envie d'éviter ce confinement on a envie
d'éviter ce couvre-feu au moment de noël
donc je crois que là tout le monde est
dans les starting blocks et je crois que
dr libe chez recharge effectivement les
chiffres de dr ils ont communiqué trois
cent cinquante mille rendez vous pris à
13h46 13h46 donc ça a dû bien à monter
depuis un et 13h46 on est un peu plus
d'une heure après les annonces du
ministre donc c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment très très rapide c'est un signe
fanny parisse de l'acceptation
finalement un autre un petit on a eu
beaucoup d'autres l'acceptation du
vaccin par les français au delà d'être
un signe d'acceptation du vaccin c'est
surtout une posture de résistance pour
la vie d'avant et pour une quête de
normalité qui commence à se faire longue
pour les individus ainsi au delà du
processus de sidération au début de
l'épidémie l'adaptabilité et le fait
qu'effectivement même sous contrainte
les individus ont réussi ce très vite à
mettre en place des routines provisoire
là il ya quand même plein d' efforts qui
sont faits de la part des individus le
vaccin les gestes barrière même s'il ya
eu un relâchement qui fait
qu'effectivement ce thé fort qui ait
demandé encore une fois et tu est un
signe est un espoir pour pouvoir passer
des fêtes de fin d'année avec ses
proches et avoir une espérance de sortie
de crise c'est encore jouable à deux
évitez le confinement sur dix sont
pessimistes et optimistes
non d'abord de celle d'un parement
optimiste j'y crois je crois fortement
au vaccin je crois fortement la
discipline des français face à tout ce
qu'on leur demande c'est c'est
restrictif les délais pour chacun pour
se faire vacciner donc je pense que tout
le monde a compris que le pass devait
venir devenait vaccinale clairement et
que ce pass vaccinale c'était un degré
de liberté et donc il ya quelque chose
qui ne va pas je trouve que de parler
ton finement alors qu'on est à la
troisième dose de vaccin et qu'on n'a
toujours pas les chiffres sur le nombre
de plus de 65 ans qui ont effectivement
eu cette troisième dose ou les personnes
qui sont à risque c'est dur ce sont ces
personnes là qui 6 millions 6000 donc si
elles sont protégés madame il elles ne
vont pas venir
créer une embolie dans les hôpitaux
elles ne vont pas venir dans une des
formes graves à l'hôpital c'est en fait
ça je trouve que vraiment pour le coup
le gouvernement fait preuve de
transparence mais toujours sur ce
problème de ces populations cibles qui
sont à risque et qui sont les plus à
risque d'embolie zh et les hôpitaux il
ya toujours un petit flou parce qu'on
craint d'être taxé de danse crimi
nationale chez terra or il faut quand
même expliquer à la population générale
qui fait un effort depuis deux ans voilà
le rapport je pense qu'il faut il faut
expliquer qu'on est avec un nouveau
variant qui est clairement beaucoup plus
agressif que les précédents il faut
expliquer à la population que il n'ya
pas comme seul indicateur l'hôpital et à
mon avis ça a été assez bien dit ce
matin tant par ses salles au mans que
par olivier ferrand pour moi virologue
il ya un indicateur c'est la circulation
du virus à partir de man legends
doublement vaccinés sont peuvent être
infectées dont sympa vlaming dit
infections me dire maladie à part du
moment on a une circulation du virus qui
est entretenue éventuellement par des
non vaccinés qui contamine dédoublement
vacciner
voilà on a en un marqueur qui fait que
l'épidémie n'est pas du tout contrôler
et surtout avec tout ce qui se passe en
europe avec tout ce qui se passe on est
vraiment laid l'europe et le centre de
l'épidémie donc je pense que le double
marque heures la circulation du virus et
l'hôpital est vraiment ce sont deux
marqueurs nécessaire à surveiller mais
christine aux yeux je reste avec votre
expertise peut-être parce qu'il faut
bien expliquer pourquoi effectivement
des gens qui sont doublement vaccinés
sont contaminés même s'il ya beaucoup
moins de forme grave même si on les
retrouve pas forcément en service de
réanimation c'est quoi c'est la charge
vaccinale qui baisent comment comment
les nantais c'est l'immunité l'immunité
contre le coran navires us qui baisse on
sait que contre les coronavirus les
immunités sont pas très très stable on
sait qu'on a des rhumes tous les âges
tous les hivers et que ses rhumes sont
liées à des coronavirus
donc entre l'immunité qui est modèle
sait qu'ils baissent elles baissent en
titre d'anticorps mais elles baissent
pas face à la résistance à la maladie l
hospitalisation donc on a quand même des
très bons marqueurs de très bonne
efficacité
delà de la vaccination cependant on est
face à un nouveau variant qui est plus
agressif que les précédents donc voilà
maintenant les gens qui sont wwe maxi né
et qui font une infection c'est assez
variable et dans l'ensemble c'est une
petite infection qui fait qu' on va même
pas chez le médecin on a 40 de fièvre ou
39 de fièvre de jours on s'arrête on
s'isole en rendez ans enfin on annonce à
ces cas contacts mais mais si vous
voulez sais c'est pas très très bien
mesuré et en même temps c'est pas très
grave quoi c'est une petite manip mais
emmanuel rivière est ce que ça renforce
pas on l'a vu on l'a vu notamment sur
l'eau sociaux ça donne pas un nouvelle
allure argumentaire aux antilles vax
finalement bien entendu et c'est un peu
la question depuis le début de cette
épidémie enfin il passé le moment de
sidération que qu'évoquer famille parise
ce qui frappe quand même c'est qu'on a à
plusieurs fois imaginé qu'on avait
atteint
le point limite même point où ça allait
se crispait le point on allait avoir une
résistance de la part de la population
on a vu cet été effectivement des
manifestations que réunissait et ce
n'était pas la même chose anti vaccins
et on y passe sanitaires et au bout du
bout ça c'est ça s'est résorbée et
finalement c'est aussi très
impressionnant de voir comment pendant
cette épidémie finalement on s'en est
remis aux autorités publiques en se
disant elles ont raison alors évidemment
qui prévoir quelque part une limite
d'acceptation mais j'aurais plutôt
tendance à imaginer compte tenu des
chiffres des sondages d'opinion en cause
étaient tout à l'heure que
c'est vrai que c'est moins binaire qu'on
ne pourrait imaginer ce à dire que les
gens se disent pas je suis pour suis
contraint il regarde ce qui se passe
ailleurs ils ont entendu parler de
confinement en autriche ils ont entendu
parler d'aggravation de la situation ils
ont la mémoire de ce qu'on a traversé
ils ont la mémoire les grands-parents la
perte des contacts avec leurs petits
enfants les étudiants la perte de tout
un tas de choses qu'il faut un petit peu
leur marché entre différentes solutions
et finalement entre plusieurs mots celui
là je pense celui qu'on sait ça se faire
vacciner par plus pour ceux qui sont
déjà vaccinés la troisième dose c'est
pas un mal si considérable s'est fait
vraiment partie des moindres maux alors
il ya également et j'appelle alexandre
pousse à nous rejoindre sur ce plateau
une dimension on va dire politique ou
d'équilibré des pouvoirs c'est ces
mesures est ce qu est ce qu il faut les
faire valider revotée par le parlement
c'est quoi le contexte alors pour mettre
en place cette petite restriction des
mesures sanitaires le gouvernement n'a
pas besoin de passer devant le parlement
tout simplement parce que eh bien le
parlement a déjà autorisé l'exécutif à
prendre ce type de mesures sanitaires
c'était il ya un mois avec à bien la
prolongation de ce qu'on appelle le
régime de sortie de crise sanitaire en
gros c'est un état d'urgence sanitaire
allégé c'est un régime juridique
d'exception qui permet au gouvernement
jusqu'au 31 juillet 2 le 22 et bien
d'abord d'instaurer le passé ni terre
c'est ce qui est bien en vigueur
aujourd'hui et puis de prendre d'autres
mesures qu'on a connus au début de la
crise à savoir fermer les établissements
recevant du public interdire les
rassemblements mettre en place un
couvre-feu ou un confinement mais
seulement au niveau local dans un
territoire bien spécifique et il ya un
mois dans le débat au parlement et bien
le sénat souhaitait donner ses pouvoirs
sanitaire d'exception gouvernement mais
seulement jusqu'au 18 février 2022 pour
que ensuite et bien le gouvernement
revienne devant les parlementaires pour
valider ce dispositif
et puis le sénat souhaitait également
assouplir le dispositif du pass
sanitaires pour qu'il s'applique
seulement aux territoires peut vacciner
notamment en outre-mer alors toutes ces
modifications du sénat elles ont été
balayées d'un revers de la main par
l'assemblée nationale qui a le dernier
mot dans la navette parlementaire et
puis avec la cinquième vague cet
assouplissement du passé ni terre n'est
plus trop d'actualité évidemment on n'a
plus vraiment ça en tête est ce que le
gouvernement a le pouvoir de confiner
dirt confiné tout le pays a oui c'est
possible pour une durée d'un mois le
gouvernement prendrait alors un décret
et puis au bout d'un mois là ils
seraient obligés de passer devant la
représentation nationale pour faire
adopter un projet de loi est bien un
restaurant l'état d'urgence sanitaire
alors c'était d'ailleurs l'an sanitaire
c'est un régime juridique d'exception
qu'on connaît bien utilisé et bien en
2020 au début de la crise sanitaire il
permet au gouvernement de prendre toutes
les mesures qu'on a vu précédemment et
en plus d'instaurer un couvre-feu ou un
confinement sur l'ensemble du territoire
alors pour l'instant il n'est pas
appliqué en france sauf en martinique et
en guyane il est en vigueur jusqu'au 31
décembre 2021 et ils permettent de
mettre en place et bien le couvre-feu
que connaissent actuellement les
guyanais et les martiniquais merci
alexandre pour toutes pour toutes ces
précisions bon évidemment je pense que
l'objectif de tout le monde autour de
cette table
ornements des scientifiques c'est
d'éviter un confinement je vais vous
donner la liste des pays qui ont pris
une décision de confinement généralisé
ou territorialisées l'autriche c'est un
confinement général il est
territorialisée en chine partiel aux
pays-bas en allemagne il ya un
confinement des non vaccinés qui a été
décidé en slovaquie russie et puis des
restrictions notamment en allemagne et
en belgique
je voulais ce jour et que vous
réagissiez tient à ce que disait
alexandre sur un un allègement par
territoire ou un confinement par
territoire ou impasse annie terre par
territoire le fait d'être finalement
dans un tamis qui tient compte des
situations et de la circulation du virus
territoire par territoire christine
est-ce que ça encore du sens aujourd'hui
avec l'accélération de la circulation
dans plus de 100 cela tout accord de la
france et a les mêmes problèmes donc
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des périodes il
ya trois semaines où il y avait la
lozère l'ardèche qu'il est plutôt ma là
c'est fini l'un c'est partout sur toute
la france d'accord bon ça ça règle là la
question d'une façon très simple je vous
ai parlé aussi des tests pcr ça c'est
une des annonces d'ententes du ministre
de la santé tests pcr qui seront
valables seulement
24 heures ça change quoi et ça change
beaucoup bah oui ça change beaucoup
parce que les gens réticents à la
vaccination
arriver à faire et spcr deux à trois
fois par semaine si jamais il en avait
besoin alors que la saison des données
moyens parce que si les moyens quand
même marseille je fais moi j'étais
j'étais vraiment
partagé est vraiment pour la gratuité
parce que c'est un handicap pour des
populations qui comprennent pas
forcément le mieux la vaccination qui en
ont le plus peur qu'ils sont des papes
ne voulait plus et les sciences souvent
marginalisées donc c'est vrai que
c'était un problème mais là le passé à
24 heures je penserai faire comprendre à
tout le monde que c'est pas possible de
le faire tous les jours à moins d'être
richissime quoi enfin ça n'a pas de ça
n'a pas beaucoup de chance plus le fait
que c'est quand même assez désagréable
mon petit fils a l'habitude de dire ils
sont allés jusqu'à mon cerveau c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que c'est quand même
pas très agréable et que en plus
franchement par rapport à une
vaccination fin c'est un geste donc je
pense que c'est un argument de
conviction assez fort oui pour ceux qui
qui était hésitant comme des idées et ça
rejoint ce qu'on dit depuis le début de
ce débat d'une certaine façon cette
impasse vaccinale qui est en train de se
mettre en place vous parliez de la
gratuité on écoute
monsieur 4 nas adrien son prénom est en
train de faire appel merci il avait le
pain sec et que mon deuxième cerveau
cayla dans l'oreillette l'actrice en
chef de l'émission adria cat-nat ce qui
réagit sur la gratuité des tests
il faut rétablir rapidement maintenant
rapidement les tests gratuits parce que
pour contraindre à la vaccination on a
rendu les tests payant pour une partie
de la population mais c'est une
formidable initiative non non pas du
tout est-ce que ça est-ce que ça poussé
certains à aller se faire vacciner mais
je suis en pose une autre question est
ce que ça nous empêche de détecter
certains malades la réponse est oui mais
quand l'organisation mondiale de la
santé jean jacques bourdin dit faut
tester tester tester ils savent pourquoi
et regarder des épidémiologistes
désormais le disent aussi il faut un
retour aux tests gratuits alors il ya
deux éléments d'abord la gratuité
l'inégalité devant le virus fanny paris
ça c'est une dimension ce qu'on parle
d'acceptabilité de la situation par
l'opinion c'est ça joue forcément à ça
joue énormément et que ce soit dans
l'acceptabilité à la fois de la gratuité
ou non des tests et de la vaccination
parce qu'en fonction de son milieu
social en fonction des contraintes
professionnelles que l'on a est
également de l'accès à certaines
informations
eh bien on va pas avoir le même discours
et on va pas agir de la même façon par
rapport à la vaccination malgré un fort
taux de vaccination ce que je peux
observer lorsque je suis sur le terrain
c'est qu'en fonction des groupes sociaux
que je vais interviewer je vais avoir
des discours totalement différent entre
ceux qui sont toujours réticents entre
ceux qui prônent à outrance la
vaccination pour eux c'est d'une
normalité assourdissantes et puis pour
les autres et qu'ils sont
dans un nombre non négligeable qui sont
vaccinées mais pour cette injonction à
la liberté qui est plus important de
pour eux malgré une réticence qui ai
toujours assumé dans leurs discours donc
à plein de situations qui sont
totalement différentes et qui sont
autant de parcours de vie qui ne se font
pas forcément dans une fluidité on va
dire psychologiques et sociales et ça
faut pas l'oublier non est-ce que c'est
toujours une source de fractures parfois
même intrafamiliales là le
positionnement par rapport au vaccin ou
est-ce que vous pensez que ça s'est
adouci une certaine façon à madrid c'est
certain que ça a réveillé des clivages
qu'on ne soupçonnait pas au sein de
l'entourage proche après il ya une
réalité que cette exigence d'avoir un
test plus récent de 24 heures va
accentuer sais que si je pense que
beaucoup de choses la teste la majorité
de la population considère que le vaccin
c'est la bonne solution pour éviter de
retomber dans des solutions pire par
définition les non vaccinés sur les gens
qui sont en plus grande résistance qui
peut être une résistance parce que tout
simplement ils ont peur de ce combat
leurs administrés et là c'est pas voilà
il faut simplement qu'on ne peut pas
savoir si c'est sûr donc c'est sûr pas
complotistes ils sont pas
soupçonneux de ce qu'on ait des
intentions méchante à leur égard il se
dit juste on ne peut pas savoir et on
s'est déjà trompé dans le passé auxquels
s'ajoutent ceux qui en revanche adhère à
une réalité totalement différente que
tout cela ce serait quelque chose
d'orchestrés dans la big pharma par avec
la complicité des pouvoirs publics
l'information j'avais donc les jours la
cgl et des traitements voilà évidemment
c'est deux groupes qui peuvent parfois
se confondre - est mis sous une
contrainte supplémentaire donc là c'est
là on peut s'attendre à ce qu'ils aient
une réaction et comme on le constate
d'ailleurs comme on l'a constaté dès le
début on peut avoir des très grande
majorité la population qui adhère aux
consignes et des gens qui ce qui
s'activent pour dire alors là non on
n'est pas d'accord sur la question des
tests jeu rebondit encore sur ce que
disait adrien 80 sur la gratuité ou pas
c'est vrai testez détecter isolé c'est
quand même un levier dans ses politiques
de lutte contre le le bio c'est ce qu'il
faudrait parvenir à la gratuité pour
plus testé de nouveau alors la gratuité
à l'avantagé que les gens vont plus vers
facilement vers le test avec un petit
symptômes de rhume c'est vrai que ça
vaut le coup c'est gratuit givet alors
que là c'est pas prescription médicale
dort on va avoir la gratuité uniquement
pour les symptomatique or il ya quand
même énormément et majoritairement d un
symptomatique porteurs de virus et y
compris par lui évidemment les non
vaccinés donc cette gratuité
n'a pas tout faire là on est peut-être
au bout du bout du bout du rouleau et
c'est vrai que c'est à mon avis la
mesure 24 heures va vraiment changer les
choses parce que là c'est vraiment un
une atteinte dans la liberté très
importante alors évidemment quand vous
êtes dans votre campagne pour la semaine
vous en fichez mais quand vous voulez
sortir et où je pense que on a évidence
que les bars les restaurants les milieux
fermés
voilà les clusters se produisent là et
les comportements et le relâchement ces
produits là et c'est là qu'on a eu
l'extension de l'épidémie donc comme je
penserai ça ça peut être aussi dans les
milieux intrafamiliaux parce que ça
c'est on retourne dans les polémiques du
premier confinement et vous l'avez dit
j'ai enlevé les agglomérations et
grosses agglomérations
correspondent à une partie de la france
mais enfin il ya toute une france aussi
rural qui se rassemblaient qui a
continué les réunions familiales dans
les villages est vraiment vérifié sur le
terrain
mais ça s'est vérifié sur le terrain
uniquement les dans les villes les bars
et les uns et non les relâcher dans vous
avez raison les soirées dansantes les
réunions sportives
les réunions familiales
la petite enfance les les crèches
si vous lisez santé publique france ils
savent très bien où vous dire où on
était les clusters et et ce qui les a
déclenché le plus célèbre est quand même
celui de récemment de la réunion des
maires de france on commence à conduire
tout cela
là on commence à compter les mouches
commencent à tomber là donc c'est vrai
que encore une fois on est passé à une
contagiosité qui nous surprend quand
même beaucoup c'est aussi la campagne
présidentielle qui est qui et qui est
ton jeu quand on y réfléchit c'est un
énorme engin conditions dans lesquelles
au rendez vous sarr de la vème
république donc son meeting ce enfin bon
on peut même pas et spéciliste et j'aime
pas les meetings ça c'est quand même
c'est quand même une vraie question pour
lever alors qu'en janvier
campagne normale ouais ouais c'est un
vrai enjeu c'est sûr que les premiers
meetings c'est début décembre à oui
biensur des risques il faudra le passé à
lutter ou pas pour aller au meeting de
jean luc mélenchon a normalement oui le
5 décembre normalement oui match et
masqués pas sanitaire
est ce que vous imaginez un candidat de
toute façon la loi oblige le porter le
masque là maintenant fallait les
nouvelles règles annoncées paoli de
vivéole en remettre le masque dans l'est
dans les lieux publics donc ça répond à
la question des meetings qui seront
forcément avec
alors les préfets vont avoir le droit de
de décider de ce qui se passe chez eux
sur les marchés noël comment les marchés
ne savent pas sanitaire c'est au liban
qui nous l'annoncé mais aussi les
préfets peuvent renforcer aussi les
mesures barrières sur les différents
lieux de réunion moi mon avis et a
vraiment nécessaire parce que chaque
fois qu'on met son masque au ça allume
une petite les miens je fasse attention
la joue et qu'on évoque maintenant
l'impact de la pandémie sur notre santé
mentale et je vais m'appuyer sur une
étude menée par votre institut par
kantar public c'était tôt au début de
l'été dernier à faire au printemps
dernier mais juin 2021 on a il ya
beaucoup d'éléments mais on en a choisi
deux qu'on va regarder ensemble
avez-vous ressenti un changement de
votre bien-être psychologique
la moyenne sur 10 pays c'est oui grosso
modo à 25% et en france la réponse
positive est beaucoup plus élevé à 37 %
comment vous analysé ce chiffre émane
sellier en fait on a aussi un chiffre
très élevé en espagne c'est lié ce que
représentent les lieux de convivialité
les modes de contact avec les autres la
manière dont on se socialise l'habitude
que l'on peut avoir d'aller au
restaurant de se croiser les uns les
autres et
effectivement la france avec ses 37 % de
gens qui disent cela atteint mon moral
se distingue et ceux qui se distinguent
aussi et notamment en france c'est la
jeune génération les 18 24 ans ont été
particulièrement affectées on monte à 47
% un jeune sur deux qui nous dit ça m'a
touché effectivement les diverses
expériences alors il y en a certaines
qu'on connaît bien privation de contact
fragilisation la situation d'études mais
augmentation des conflits familiaux ça
n'a pas été toujours que du bonheur se
retrouver coincés à la maison avec papa
maman pour les étudiants
incertitude sur le devenir scolaire tout
ça est
également et voire même d'ailleurs
augmentation pratiques de consommation
d'alcool moins de religion de vie donc
trek tout c'est tous ces dégâts
collatéraux
déconfinement je pense voilà permet de
relativiser c'est un stand de
contraintes par rapport à ça le masque
je leur mette finalement c'est quelque
chose qui est finalement tellement
acceptable
pour rebondir c'est ce que vous venez de
dire la notion de santé mentale qui
était un peu un tabou dans le monde de
l'entreprise moi je travaille aussi sur
une scène économique s'appelle bismarck
je reçois beaucoup de chefs d'entreprise
qui maintenant ouvertement on parle de
santé mentale mettent en place des
stratégies pour améliorer la santé
mentale de leurs salariés alors que
c'était un discours qu'on entend des
affaires comme moi je n'entendais pas du
tout les deux trois années précédant le
choc que c'est si on veut chercher un
effet positif à une crise sanitaire
comme celle là c'en est un mon fanny
parizon on est déjà mais on va sortir
j'espère qu'on va en sortir un jour
changer dans nos comportements de cette
de cette crise sanitaire on a déjà
changé oui messieurs faire l'expérience
collectivement d'une crise comme
celle-ci même si un jour on a un retour
à la normale cette normalité ne sera
jamais totalement celle d'avant parce
que toutes les expériences de vie qu'on
a eue ce nouveau rapport aux risques et
à la confiance par rapport à nous mêmes
par rapport aux autres et à l'invisible
qui est ce virus nous a changé à tout
jamais et pour rebondir sur ce que vous
venez de dire par rapport aux
changements dans l'entreprise on
m'appelle de plus en plus pour faire des
conférences sur la notion de confiance
de responsabilité et de risques pour
essayer de voir comment on ne va pas
forcément
à vers un retour à la normale mais vers
une hybridation qui a fait qu'en
fonction de ce que les individus ont
vécu ce qu'ils ont été concernés par le
télétravail parce que c'est quand même
pas la majorité des individus ont envie
d'avoir une hybridation qui va avoir un
impact à la fois sur la gestion du foyer
du domicile mais également sur les lieux
de travail sur les âmes unité de
proximité et c'est juste concernant
l'entreprise 84% ces sondages au doxa
d'hier 84% serait favorable à un
élargissement du télétravail là il ya un
hiatus entre la politique
gouvernementale qui quand même freine le
télétravail à on voit qu'il ya un
problème au niveau des entreprises
gouvernance et au tessin pas d'accord
bah c'est parce que et des syndicats
sont pas forcément d'accord
on voit bien que la vidéo parce que vous
pointez du doigt madame les bars les
lieux de convivialité je suis tout à
fait d'accord mais dans l'entreprise si
n'importe qui se balade à bord une
entreprise vraiment le masque a été très
beaux arts d ivoire les entreprises on
va parler des écoles maintenant
on va parler des écoles avec ce nouveau
protocole dans les écoles primaires
annoncé par le ministre de l'éducation
nationale
je vous proposes tu viens d'écouter jean
michel dans cas pour commencer il n'y
aura donc plus de fermeture systématique
de classes dès le 1er 4 vide en primaire
mais un dépistage systématique de toute
la classe
autrement dit seuls les élèves
présentant un test négatif pourront
revenir en classe et ça pas de fermeture
de classe systématique test des élèves
dès l'apparition d'un cas réintégration
des élèves testés négatifs racing
rouzioux qu'est ce que vous en pensez ah
enfin
enfin fait fermer enfin une classe et
laisser les enfants à la maison pendant
une semaine c'était vraiment très lourd
pour les enfants pour les vieillards ans
oui mais je pense que je pense que
c'était et ce n'était pas raisonnable
dans la mesure où a priori il
suffit de les tester le tass antigènes
marche très bien et donc il n'y avait
même pas d'injonction pour le test donc
c'était quand même un peu bizarre
évidemment moi je disais à mes enfants
bon il est à la maison mais testent le
camp il faut que tu saches illicites et
s'il est vraiment contact ou pas en plus
c'était tout à fait un complet comme
mesure est pas raisonnable parce que il
ya bien sûr des frères et soeurs en face
voilà c'était mal mesuré là je pense et
puis et alors que le gouvernement avait
au début pensé avoir beaucoup plus de
tests à l'école ça n'a pas bien marché
ça n'a pas du tout il ya marché du tout
et c'est vrai que là ça touche les
petits et donc je pense qu'on va venir à
la question des 5 12 ans j'espère y
arriver vite on va en parler tout de
suite le taux d'incidence et les 6 10
ans et santé publique france qui donne
ces chiffres
340 contre 191 pour la population
générale vous voyez venir avec mes gros
sabots la question faut-il vacciner les
enfants bah il faut ces chiffres là pour
faire comprendre aux gens que les
enfants peuvent représenter un bon
réservoir de virus avec tout ce que ça
comporte pour voir les grands parents à
noël etc etc donc je pense que là ça y
est on y est le risque de
cardiomyopathie cannes de myocardite
chez l'enfant est bien supérieur chez
les enfants non vaccinés par rapport aux
enfants vaccinés donc cette peur de
l'a27
myocardite et est de moins en moins
justifiée parce que on a beaucoup
d'expérience aux états unis a une très
grosse expérience en israël voilà on
attend en france à un but d'étendre lé l
épreuve la l'épreuve arrivent elles sont
en train de tomber et surtout le
gouvernement est en train de commander
les doses les doses enfants parce que
c'est pas la même doses pour vacciner
les enfants les adultes ministre de la
santé l'a dit ce serait pas avant
janvier 2022 le temps d'avoir les deux
c'est ça donc on aura passé noël de
toute façon israël etats unis canada qui
ont autorisé la vaccination des enfants
et puis avec le vaccin chinois la chine
les émirats arabes unis le cambodge la
colombie et
à cuba et également avec un vaccin
cubain sur sur cette question de la
vaccination des enfants c'est pas si
simple dans l'opinion quand même mal ou
bien parce que alors moi les miens ils
sont ils sont très très grand 28 et 25
mai ce jeu je m'imagine avec mes jeunes
enfants me dire bon bah ils risquent pas
d'attraper la maladie mais il faut quand
même que je les vaccine pour protéger
les autres mais est-ce qu'ils sont ça va
les mettre en gir vous voyez ce cette
espèce de maelström d'athènes qu'on peut
avoir dans la tête quoi en fait la
question à la vaccination des enfants ça
montre bien un des enjeux enfin je pense
ou votre contrôle il ya une question de
rapport bénéfice risque individuel et
une question le rapport bénéfice/risque
collectivisation qui préside aussi à la
vaccination qui domine dans les zombies
de certains de toute façon heureusement
et la l'extension du champ de blé de
privilégier un
truc de privilégier l'intérêt collectif
à l'instar oui pour certains pour
certains certaines personnes pensent que
vacciner son enfant pour les autres
c'est voilà c'est pas une raison il faut
avoir une
humble et fils individuel avant le
bénéfice net team c'est là où ça change
un petit peu la chose parce que le
décision qu'on a pu prendre beaucoup moi
j'en ai une de cet âge-là de vacciner
les 12 18 ans ben on a un dialogue avec
son enfant qui comptait à fin mai de
vérifier comment il ou elle sans la
chose
là on va on va parler d'enfants dont
onze y moi je suis obligé de prendre la
décision pour lui mais je pense que il
ya toutes les raisons de penser que ça a
fonctionné comme pour le reste c'est à
dire que le fait que aux états unis
comme vous l'avez dit au canada au fur à
mesure que ça va se réaliser par les
gens sont un peu soulagés quelque chose
qu'on avait clairement mis à jour
lorsqu'on avait eu à travailler sur
l'extension du champ de l'obligation
vaccinale à 11 vaccin beaucoup de gens
étaient réticents et quand on leur
disait mais vous savez c'est déjà le cas
de 80% des enfants beaucoup de gens
disent ah bon 6 si c'est déjà le cas
alors c'est pas tant que ça un problème
en fait beaucoup de gens ont besoin
d'être rassurés par le fait que c'est
déjà en place il se passe rien de
dramatique un mot un mot de deux
conclusions sur ce thème là aussi votre
d'un point de vue sur les enfants d'un
point de vue anthropologique le permis
prescrits et l'interdît change
énormément quand c'est pour soi ou quand
c'est pour quelqu'un dont on est
responsable donc moi ce que je peux dire
humblement est vraiment d'un point de
vue anthropologique c'est de se dire que
peut-être le fait d'avoir un parent
vaccinés qui l'a vu qu'ils n'avaient pas
forcément d'effets secondaires et qu'il
a pu retrouver ses libertés maps et est
une incitation à lever certains freins
pour la vaccination des enfants mais ça
questionne quand même l'injonction
vaccinale par rapport à cette liberté de
continuer à vivre normalement au delà de
pouvoir avoir des activités sociales
comme c'était le cas au début de la
campagne vaccinale merci beaucoup merci
à tous d'avoir participé à ce débat nous
avoir éclairé et d'avoir éclairé les
téléspectateurs de public sénat